[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 78 sur TV 78
nous sommes le mardi 17 octobre voici
les titres le château de Versailles
fermé pendant plusieurs heures cet
après-midi comme samedi dernier le site
des ivelines a dû être de nouveau évacué
à la mi-journée après une alerte à la
bombe il a rouvert vers 15h30 et
l'édifice est fréquenté à cette époque
de l'année par 10000 à 15000 touristes
dont de nombreux étrangers que nous
avons rencontrés sur place le souvenir
de Samuel pati toujours présent à
conflan saint-onorine 3 ans jour pour
jour après l'assassinat du professeur
d'histoire géographie un rassemblement
se tenait hier dans la ville en présence
de plus de 400 personnes une douleur
ravivée avec le meurtre vendredi dernier
de l'enseignant Dominique Bernard
nouvelle victime du terrorisme islamiste
c'est une association historique de 50
ans en Eveline gravure change d'adresse
mais pas d'activité les bénévoles ont
quitté hlencour pour coignè dans des
locaux mises à disposition par la mairie
les presses et machines à graver vont
pouvoir reprendre du service certaines
pèsent plus d'une tonne et puis elle
œuvre dans les quartiers prioritaires
pour faire connaître la musique
classique au plus grand nombre
l'Association pour la musique de 50 ans
en Eveline est investi de cette mission
depuis 30 ans désormais nous avons suivi
ses actions pendant près de 6 mois un
documentaire sera prochainement diffusé
sur tv78 extrait en 2è partie d'émission
dans les invités du 78
et Michel midoro est avec moi en plateau
bonsoir Michel de la rédaction tv78 on
débute ce 78 par cette information le
château de versaill encore évacué
aujourd'hui après une nouvelle alerte à
la bombe on le voit sur ces images
partagé sur les réseaux sociaux après
une première évacuation le weekend
dernier le site le plus fréquenté des
iin a de nouveau été évacué après une
alerte à la bombe en fin de matinée ce
mardi 17 octobre une personne a donné
une fausse alerte sur la plateforme de
chat de la police nationale
moncommissariat.fr en disant qu'il y
avait 900 qui kilo d'explosif dans le
château et qu'il allait tout faire péter
10000 visiteurs étaient présents dans
les lieux et dans le parc et jardin du
château au moment de cette évacuation
totale qui s'est terminé vers 13h15 les
salariés du site et les touristes ont dû
attendre devant le château pendant
plusieurs heures on écoute les réactions
des
visiteurs c'est vraiment une situation
très effrayante on vient juste d'arriver
et on ne savait pas ce qui s'était passé
je suis très confusé parce
que je je je ne sait pas que ça ça fermé
les alertes à la bombe ben c'est à
prendre au sérieux je vais attendre et
puis je ferai plus tard l'avantage des
retraités qui sont pas en train de
courir après
l'heure le château a rouvert ses portes
aux alentours de 15h30 après
vérification des des mineurs donc
normalement ouverture également demain
pour le château de Versailles rappelons
que la France Saint- Michel est placé
toujours en alerte urgence attentat
depuis l'assassinat du professeur
Dominique Bernard à haras la sécurité
également renforcée à la frontière
franco-belge au lendemain de l'attentat
à Bruxelles hein qui a fait deux morts
hier lundi 16 octobre nous commémorions
les 3 ans de l'assassinat de Samuel pati
à Conflant saint-honorine pour lui
rendre un nouvel hommage la Ville a
organisé un rassemblement hier soir
Place de la Liberté et plus de 400
personnes se sont mobilisées pour ne pas
oublier Gabriel gonther et Mathilde
Francou uni contre l'oubli 3 ans après
son assassinat le souvenir de Samuel
paatti était toujours présent hier soir
àonflant saint-onorine près de 400
personnes étaient réunies pour rendre
hommage au professeurs
d'histoire-géographie pour nous
Conflanais ce rassemblement est
particulier car elle ramène chacune et
chacun d'entre nous à cette terrible
soirée du 16 octobre 2020 après l'homage
rendu par le maire de la ville une
minute de silence a été observée en
souvenir du professeur assassiné le 16
octobre 2020 par un terroriste
islamiste un moment solennel est rempli
d'émotions auxquelles il était important
d'assister pour les personnes présentes
on éta dé il y a 3 ans on est on reste
dans le même état d'esprit et ce n'était
pas pensable de ne pas venir même moi je
suis vraiment horrifié j'habite à 200 m
de l'endroit où il a été assassiné je
passe à cet endroit bien sûr presque
tous les
jours j'ai du mal à M remettre Samuel
Pat est mort alors que c'est injuste en
fait c'est juste quelqu'un qui a déformé
la phrase un temps de recueillement
nécessaire aussi pour réaffirmer les
valeurs de la République et de la
liberté c'est important ce moment de de
rassemblement et de recueillement aussi
pour ne jamais oublier à quel point
l'obscurantisme pouvait faire mal et
c'est aussi une manière de dire que nous
ne cèderons pas face à ça que nous
restons unis que nous restons debout
collègu anciens élèves et Conflanais ont
ensuite déposé des gerbes de fleurs
devant le monument pour la liberté
d'expression érigé en mémoire de
l'enseignant une façon d'aider les
Conflanais à tourner la page mais à ne
jamais
oublier on fait le point à présent sur
les autres actualités du
jour avec des rassemblements Mel
toujours en hommage à le professeur
assassinat aras qui sont poursuivis ce
mardi dans les ivelines nous étions hier
à manilamo et à plaisir mais c'est
quiment l'ensemble des communes de 50
ans en yvine qui ont organisé des
rassemblements hier soir les habitants
d'élencour étaient appelés à se
mobiliser aux alentours de 18h sur le
parvis de l'Hôtel de Ville des minutes
de silence ont également été observées
ce mardi c'était le cas à midi à trappe
devant la mairie mais aussi à coignir
toujours à midi le rassemblement s'est
déroulé cette fois-ci à l'intérieur de
l'hôtel de ville plusieurs dizaines
d'habitants étaient présents à chaque
fois pour ces tsommage même près de 300
personnes pour la ville de trappe on a
vu une image s'afficher le verdict est
tombé pour le fichs qui a été arrêté
vendredi à Limet l'individu a été
condamné à 6 mois de prison en ferme
avec maintien en détention par le
tribunal correctionnel de Versailles
vendredi le même jour que l'assassinat
de Dominique Bernard haras l'homme a été
arrêté avec un couteau aux abords du
lycée condorsé de Limet ce dernier est
connu des services de police pour au
moins cinq faits similaires des photos
de décapitation aurent été également été
retrouvé sur son portable en revanche
aucune infraction terroriste n'a été
retenue contre lui lors de son jugement
en comparution immédiate on va sortir un
peu de cette actualité difficile avec la
présence ce matin dans les yeelines d'un
ministre ce matin le ministre du Travail
du plein emploi et de l'insertion
Olivier dus sopt était à trrappe il est
venu au secteur d'action sociale
présenté le projet d'accompagnement
renforcé des bénéficiaires du RSA pour
favoriser la réinsertion professionnelle
parcours individualisé moins
d'interlocuteurs et plus de contact avec
les employeurs du territoire depuis
juillet 2023 4800 allocataires résidents
sur 50 ans livin expérimentent ce
nouveau dispositif jusqu'à fin 2024 on
écoute les réactions micro de Julien
luroy quand on regarde les chiffres au
niveau national on voit que sur les
1950000 allocataires du RSA 42 % sont
RSA depuis plus de 7 ans et et nous
avons une difficulté de retour à
l'emploi je pense que dans une période
où le chômage baisse où les entreprises
crent d'emploi où nous considérons que
tout le monde est employable c'est
important de tout mettre en œuvre pour
accompagner ce celles et ceux qui sont
les plus éloignés il y a plus de moyens
et il y a un partage des informations et
un partage des compétences et pour
l'interlocuteur pour celui qui est en
face de de ses collaborateurs et de PUL
emploi et du département c'est très
apaisant parce qu'il a on lui fait son
guichet unique devant lui il a toutes
les compétences qui s'ouvrent un mot de
sport et de rugby ils sont là Michel les
All Black sont dans les Yvelines oui la
Nouvelle-Zélande va préparer toute cette
semaine sa demi-finale de Coupe du monde
à Croatie sur scène les blacks sont
arrivés hier soir et se sont entraînés
sur le terrain du stade municipal ils
affronteront l'Argentine ce vendredi
soir à 21h au Stade de France pour une
place en finale eux qui ont pour
objectif de soulever un 4e titre mondial
malheureusement pour le public et pour
vous hein Grégory canalé tous les
entraînements vont se dérouler à hucllos
je suis très déçu je suis très déçu de
pour pas pouvoir voir les All Black pour
terminer retour sur un événement qui
s'est déroulé à mentini le Bretonneux du
10 au 15 octobre c'était la 20e édition
de la Semaine du handicap à Montini le
breteneux la commune organisée nouveau
de nombreux rendez-vous dont le point
d'org était le grand jeu défi en famille
le dimanche des sensibilisations mais
aussi du recrutement le vendredi 13 se
tenait au sein de l'Hôtel de Ville un
forum du recrutement une dizaine
d'entreprises avent fait le déplacement
avec plus d'une centaine d'offres
d'emploi à la clé les personnes en
situation de handicap qui sont
spécifiquement conviés à
l'événement on est en partenariat avec
Cap Emploi PUL emploi et la jefip qui en
amont donc sélectionne des CV de
personnes en situation de handicap pour
que cela matche avec les différentes
offres que qu'ont les entreprises c'est
très très important parce que voilà nous
aussi ça veut dire que on peut servir à
quelque chose à la société voilà
handicap ça veut pas dire que comme moi
personnellement je le pensais je pensais
que handicap ça veut dire que c'est fini
le fait que ça soit vraiment un forum
accès handicap pour le coup les
personnes sont un peu plus en confiance
euh et on voilà on a le temps de parler
un peu plus avec eux de les rassurer
aussi hein puisque bah c'est vrai que
des fois c'est pas toujours simple
d'être confronté aussi à des
recrutements merci michaell et si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes témoin
d'une actualité qui vous fait réagir
dans les evelines n'hésitez pas à la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news l'Institut de promotion de la santé
de 50 ans en yelin organiséit samedi
dernier des ateli et des moments de
convivialité pour tous les prédents et
leur famillees l'entrédans village était
l'occasion pour eux de partager leur
quotidien et de s'évader le reportage de
Régine ralche une journée pour vous
ressourcer c'était le thème d'entrée
dans village à Plaisir plusieurs points
d'information étai organisés dont un
comptoir des aidents animé par le pôle
autonomie territoire de Versailles
SaintQuentin en Yveline on va s'occuper
plus précisément des personnes âgées et
des personnes en situation de handicap
la MDPH et donc les personnes alors que
ce soit les aidés ou les aidants
viennent dans nos services pour avoir
des informations un événement qui relève
parfois d'une grande importance pour les
proch dents on dit ce n'est pas toi qui
est malade c'est lui ou
elle mais on a du mal à réellement se
mettre dans la place de l' dents et du
coup la reconnaissance de l' dents est
vraiment important à l'heure actuelle
parce qu'il y en a de plus en plus les
aides à domicile les associations c'est
bien mais quelque part quand on voit les
problèmatique qu'on peut rencontrer au
niveau des aides à domicile ça peut être
compliqué et nous donner davantage de
travail des ateliers ludiques ont été
organisés comme les débats théâtrre ou
encore les ateliers de cuisine pour
s'évader parler des problématiques que
peuvent avoir les participants sur un
manque d'appétit par exemple sur le fait
de devoir enrichir les repas sur un
manque d'idée en fait aussi dans dans
les repas donc c'est un atelier un petit
peu interactif avec voilà qui va mêler
le fait de faire soi-même c'est c'est
pas moi qui fait les recettes ce sont
les participants qui font les recettes
prochain événement mercredi 18 octobre
un café entédent aura lieu à la maison
de voisinage de
coignère jusqu'à la fin du mois c'est
toujours octobre rose le mois de
sensibilisation au cancer du sein qui
touche en France une femme sur neu pour
l'occasion la ville de Plaisir
organisait une manifestation sportive
solidaire au choix marche ou course à
pied les dons on été reversés à
l'association à chacun son Éverest qui
accompagne des femmes en rémission d'un
cancer du sein 10000 € ont été récolté à
l'occasion de nouveau Régine ralèche
10750 c'est le montant récolté par la
marche plaisiroise octobre rose destiné
à l'association à chacun son évereste
l'association accompagne des femmes en
rémission d'un cancer du sein en leur
proposant des séjours ces fonds ils vont
servir à continuer à pouvoir entretenir
le logement continuer à pouvoir les
accompagner dans leur séjours payer la
nourriture payer le fonctionnement de de
l'association tout simplement une
mobilisation inédite c'est la prière
fois que la ville organisait une
manifestation sportive pour cette cause
on a fait un appel à la population pour
organiser des marches ou des courses à
pied et on a pratiquement 1000 inscrits
à quelque chose près donc c'est fabuleux
parce que tout le monde est venu des
grands des petits des jeunes du rose en
veux-tu en voilà parmi les participants
des adultes des enfants des hommes mais
surtout des femmes dont certaines ont
été atteintes de la maladie elles sont
venues pour soutenir l'action moi je
suis très sensible au cancer parce que
j'en ai moi-même eu un et beaucoup de
membres de ma famille ont eu et il y a
quelques semaines maintenant on m'a dit
que c'était terminé j'avais plus de
concert donc c'est pour ça que je suis
là et c'est pour ça que mes copines
elles sont là les dons sont toujours
possibles via le site de la ville de
Plaisir bravo à tous les participants
allez on ouvre une page culture dans le
[Musique]
78 pour ces 40 ans gravure change de
locaux auparavant installé dans la zone
artisanale des quatre arbres à hlencour
l'association a déménagé à coignère elle
a officiellement inauguré ses nouveaux
locaux il y a quelques jours visite avec
Mélanie poquet et Régine ralche elles
ont juste changé de lieu les presses
dont certaines pèsent plus d'une tonne
et autres machines à gravé ont retrouvé
leurs activités ainsi que la quarantaine
d'adhérents l'association
gravure a pris possession de ces
nouveaux locaux de 100 m Carr c'est
super même s'ils sont plus petit que ce
que nous avions mais du coup on a
optimisé tous c ces mètres carrés et on
trouve finalement on s'y sent bien on
trouve que que ça c'est très convivial
et on arrive à à à on a moins d'espace
entre les les différents postes de
travail mais c'est tout à fait suffisant
fondé il y a 41 ans l'association était
jusqu'à présent à hlencour la raison de
son déménagement les travaux de la zone
anal des qure arbres son point de chute
le centre commercial du village
aquanière j'ai considéré que l'activité
d'art gravure était une activité
importante c'est un véritable patrimoine
un patrimoine immatériel avec ses
adhérents qui sont des artistes et un
patrimoine matériel avec ce que vous
voyez ici c'est-à-dire l'ensemble des
presses c'est une fierté pour moi parce
que c'est une association qui s'inscrit
dans l'histoire et moi je suis prof
d'histoire donc quelque part ça me
touche prochain rendez-vous de
l'association le marché de Noël de la
ville de coanière et les portes ouvertes
en décembre art gravure peut maintenant
graver un nouveau chapitre de son
histoire comme tous les mardis une salle
du territoire vous donne trois raisons
d'aller voir sa prochaine programmation
ce soir la meurise de trappe nous parle
de l'après-midi d'un faone spectacle
pour petits et grands de la compagnie n
Nova fiaaménard c'est le dimanche 19
novembre pour vous convaincre Pauline
crépi au micro de Mathilde Francou
bonjour bonjour à tous je suis Pauline
CRPI je travaille à la Merise où je suis
directrice adjointe et chargée du jeune
public aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
du spectacle l'après-midi d'un faone et
vous donner trois raisons de venir le
[Musique]
voir la première raison c'est que c'est
un spectacle absolument spectaculaire
c'est un balai de sac plastique animé
par des ventilateurs on n jamais vu ça
la deuxième c'est un spectacle
absolument merveilleux où retrouve la
musique de Claude dubsy l'après-midi
d'un faone et enfin la troisème c'est
parce que c'est notre coup de cœur à la
meuce pour le jeune public je pense que
c'est un spectacle que tout le monde
devrait voir à la fois les enfants et
les plus grands voilà c'était mes trois
raisons pour aller voir l'après-midi
d'un faone le dimanche 19 novembre à 15h
à la
[Musique]
Merise avant de passer à la suite jetons
un coup d'œil aux prévisions météo de
demain
[Musique]
une météo plus douce pour les
températures mais de la pluie prévue
pour votre journée de mercredi il fera
entre 11 et 14°gr le matin sur le
territoire ivelinois l'après-midi la
pluie toujours le thermomètre affichera
16°gr à Versailles et man-elajolie 15°gr
à Rambouillet et jusqu'à 17°gr à Houdan
et demain mercredi 18 octobre nous
fêterons les Lucs tout de suite les
invités du
en novembre tv78 vous proposera un
documentaire en immersion avec laapmsq
l'Association pour la musique à 50 ans
en Eveline depuis 30 ans elle œuvre dans
les quartiers prioritaires pour faire
connaître la musique classique au plus
grand nombre Julien Leroi a suivi
l'association pendant près de 6 mois
voici un extrait du
documentaire
jolis
déguisement on dit c'est des grandes
interrogation est-ce que la musique est
un loisir on sait aujourd'hui pour des
recherches c'est qu'elle est même
constitutionnelle de l'être humain on a
des connexion neuronales des lambrons
qui sont prêtes à accueillir la musique
donc on voit bien que c'est bien au-delà
que du loisir et et l'émotion après ça
c'est ce qu'elle apporte au niveau de la
concentration au niveau de la
mémorisation de toutes les attitudes qui
sont nécessaires euh à réfléchir à vivre
et puis après c'est ce qu'elle apporte
dans l'émotion et ça c'est très
personnel mais c'est aussi essentiel hop
jusqu'au plafond on s'étire on s'étire
on s'étire on s'étire ah ah tu es
magnifique en papillon c'est super beau
j'adore je vais une fois par semaine
dans chacune des classes que
j'accompagne et donc je leur ai préparé
de quoi travailler individuellement
aussi et ensemble on apprend la musique
on apprend les mélodies on apprend les
textes on l'inscrit dans l'œuvre en
règle générale souvent il y a des
morceaux qui sont en questionréponse
comme des espèces de dialogue donc il
faut faut qu'on apprenne comme ça à
écouter les autres qu'on anticipe le
moment où les autres vont chanter et
puis et puis du coup petit à petit comme
ça par petite touche de peinture par
petite touche de de notes de musique et
ben on construit toute l'œuvre toute la
partie que nous on a on coupe tous
ensemble sur le 5è temps 2
3 nous allons réunir 350 enfants des
écoles de la communauté de commune de 50
anvine sur un opéra d'Étienne Perruchon
donc une œure contemporaine qui
s'appelle Dogora où le compositeur a
inventé une langue a inventé un peuple a
inventé du coup l'histoire de ce peuple
et la culture de ce peuple et donc nous
on chante cette culture là tous ensemble
il va y avoir des collégiens de la ville
de trappe il va y avoir la maîtrise de
la ville de trappe et un cœur d'adulte
et en plus parce que ça n'est pas
suffisant un orchestre symphonique et un
chanteur lyrique professionnel on tien
grand on ti grand à l'origine c'est
intéressant comme idée parce que il y
avait l'idée de réunir des professeurs
de musique des différentes écoles de
musique ou conservatoire de
Saint-Quentin donc je trouve il y avait
une notion d'unité et c'était l'Ensemble
orchestral de Saint-Quentin env qui
donnait des concerts on leur a permis
d'augmenter le nombre de leurs concerts
la pmsq a commencé donc c'est son
activité en 2001 wouh magnifique comme
souvent les aventures elles commencent
par une rencontre donc la rencontre
c'était Hervé Farge on va chanter on va
chanter aussi le soutien de la ville de
trappe avec notamment son maire Kim
alandin j'ai pris donc la la présidence
en fait en 2001 et j'ai donc changé la
les statuts de de l'association elle
s'appelait promotion de la musique et
nous on trouvait que c'était pas
suffisant de donner des concerts qui
étai des concerts de d'amateur éclairés
donc on a choisi de vraiment d'aller
dans le domaine de la
promotion je me suis rapproché d'un chef
d'orchestre c'était le chef associer de
Jean-Claude casatsu à Lille je lui avais
demandé du coup de me faire un audit de
la pmsq parce que je sentais qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui qui n'allait pas
et en fait il est arrivé exactement à la
même conclusion que moi on ne fait rien
au niveau du nouveau public en théorie
on devrait créer un nouveau public et
que cette musique musique classique
devienne un lien
[Musique]
social un jour Jean-Claude casatsu lui a
demandé de faire des concerts pour les
milieux défavorisés al là il a une idée
extraordinaire c'est que il s'est
approché rapproché d'un directeur d'une
école élémentaire de roubet une des
régions de France les plus défavorisé et
ensemble ils sont dit ben on va monter
un spectacle ensemble avec l'école et
puis on va le donner donc à la à
l'auditorium le grand le Grand
Auditorium à Lille du coup quand il m'a
raconté tout ça ça allait exactement
dans le sens où je voulais aller mais
moi si je voulais lancer tout ça il il
me je pouvais pas aller voir un élu puis
lui dire voilà j'ai une idée comme ça
mais il m'aurait pas cru quoi d'où cette
rencontre m'a permis de de voir
comprendre complètement ça et puis du
coup de se dire ben on va essayer de
monter ça à 51
[Musique]
enline c'est pas mal du
tout et puis après c'est évidemment
c'est j'allais dire c'est un amour de
va je sais à quel point la musique pe
transforme ma vie je sais qu'elle peut
aussi transformer la vie de de tout le
[Musique]
monde j'ai un peu peur mais bon je suis
s que ça va bien se passer chanter avec
d'autres enfants couper en même temps
garder le rythme toute la
musique au début ça paraît compliqué
mais après on s'y fait et on y
arrive et pour voir le documentaire
complet rendez-vous en novembre sur tv78
voilà c'est la fin du 78 merci pour
votre fidélité demain nouvelle édition
et ce sera avec Mathilde Francou belle
soirée sur
tv78
[Musique]